virendra Patty has been looking for
signs of life for the past several days
now he's finally found some and he's
relieved a sea turtle has left tracks
along the shore we noticed the tracks
this morning and we followed them we saw
that the tracks led back to the water
then we check to see whether the turtle
had laid any eggs we found a dip but we
figured the turtle must have gotten her
flippers caught in some roots so she
just went back to the sea every morning
at around five o'clock virendra and his
colleague Samir mahadik checked the
beach for turtle tracks and nests they
work for an animal protection program
headed by mohan Upadhyaya if they find
turtle eggs they bring them to this
protected incubation area they Ribery
the eggs in the sand and place a basket
over them to keep them warm the
incubation period is about 50 days yummy
a little too subtle sons are claiming it
every day we look for dugout patches in
the sand what'd ya leave that I mean if
there's any movement you can see it in a
shanty there depletion able to study
that can mean that the eggs have hatched
and the baby turtles are trying to crawl
to the surface when we find them we take
them to the sea only a few of the baby
turtles will survive one reason for this
is water pollution just 1 in 1,000
turtles will reach the age at which they
can start breeding 20 years the turtles
we see around here are the Olive Ridley
species they're about this big and weigh
about 50 kilos they're the smallest of
the sea turtles any samudra kazan molly
i segreti ortiz a day mohan and his
colleagues live in the village of villas
on the west coast of india about 500
people live in the village many of them
are farmers
they grow crops including pepper cashew
nuts and mangos
the kids at the school are learning
about the local environment Mohan
regularly meets with the teachers to
discuss the content of their lectures
the children learn why it's important to
protect the coastline the courses are
supported by an international
development company that's owned by the
German government the company is known
for short as the GI Z Mohan has been
fascinated by animals since he was a
child when he discovered that sea
turtles in this part of India were
facing extinction he signed up with an
Indian NGO called SNM they started a
safe the turtles program 13 years ago
here's a rare sight these baby turtles
have just hatched and they had
instinctively for the water
violets invalidly the turtles have
always laid their eggs on our beaches
but people or predatory animals used to
take the eggs and eat them some
environmentalists found empty egg shells
on the beach and decided to protect the
turtles and their eggs they also
explained to local residents why the
turtles are so important mohans
religious faith also plays a role in his
work many people in India believe that
turtles are sacred mission we consider
Turtles an incarnation of Lord Vishnu in
many homes you'll see images of him in
this incarnation people are emotionally
attached to these images they bring good
luck the animals have holy status so we
pray to them they're also good for the
local tourism industry visitors travel
from big cities just to see them there
aren't any hotels in velas so they stay
with local families for the equivalent
of about eight euros a night the number
of such homestays has grown over the
last decade the Jamuna mimd the turtles
provide jobs but this year only 8
turtles lay their eggs here and the
numbers are falling every year we're
quite upset we don't know what we do
without our turtles gorillas
and what about all the garbage in the
ocean right where the turtles are trying
to nest mohan and his colleagues Philip
bag after bag with refuse that washes up
on shore
but they say they're fighting a losing
battle yeah cardium with itself a shark
in that I work did you got at high tide
a lot of garbage ends up on the beaches
it's very dangerous for the Turtles i'm
all shaky burnham-on-sea Mohan suspects
the turtles mistake floating plastic
bags for jellyfish and try to eat them
that's why it's hard to find turtles
around here I was searching for
different kinds of species in Turtles
since last three years and I was very
keen to come here I got this chance this
year unfortunately but still
unfortunately we are not able to see
anything as the Sun sets mohan and his
colleagues are covering up the turtle
eggs in the sand again they hope the
eggs will hatch soon that will give the
tourists something to marvel at
elephant